new poll found that of the 14 percent of
voters who are not committed to either
candidate
24 favor locking down again but
70 percent say it's time to move on and
adapt
joining me now is the man behind that
poll scott rasmussen pollster
and ballotpedia editor at large scott
i've been saying since about
april or maybe early may
this is a question between liberty and
lockdown
liberty versus lockdown freedom versus
lockdown
is that perhaps coming to the fore now
i think the attitude you're describing
is coming to the fore right now but
probably not in that terminology
americans want to find ways they are
frustrated with mask mandates they are
frustrated with
over-the-top lockdowns still want to
proceed with a degree of caution and for
the most part what people want is to
have more authority to make their own
decisions so you might talk about that
in in freedom terminology but for most
people it's just practical common sense
if i go to a place and i feel
uncomfortable
well i'm gonna maybe not go in if i feel
okay i may take my mask off they want to
have that freedom
and anybody trying to create a nanny
state mindset of telling people what
they should do
that tends to push these voters away um
president trump made
that position on lockdowns clear
obviously tonight and
said this i left north carolina
which i love i left pennsylvania
we won a big case in michigan because
that governor has
a lockdown where nobody but her husband
can do anything he can go boating and do
whatever he wants but nobody else can
the fact is we're winning all these
cases because it's unconstitutional what
they're doing and i think they're doing
it for political reasons
but the fact is the cure you can't you
can't let this continue to go on with
the lockdowns
scott does that messaging work
especially with suburban moms who are
seeing what's happening
to their children who are being kept
from schools
especially in the area where we live dc
maryland and virginia it's been
very tough you know suburban voters
suburban moms
are concerned about this in fact the the
desire for more lockdowns and stricter
controls is pretty much confined to
urban areas and democratic urban voters
uh having said that we're talking about
issues we're only talking about moving a
few voters here and there you said at
the open
14 of voters are uncommitted you know
these might be voters who say they're
voting for a libertarian now or who
might change their mind to one of the
major party candidates
it comes in the context of joe biden is
ahead narrowly in my state polls in the
national polling we're seeing
but a shift of a couple of points can
move this right back in a toss-up
category and this is an issue that might
do it and that most pundits will miss
scott great to see you tonight thank you
for joining